all right
cool well i'm going to go ahead and get
started because it is 40 after
wherever you're at um welcome everybody
my name
is scott and today i'm going to be
talking to you about
the background on background tasks in
net core i have already posted these
slides both
on my blog which is just my first and
last name dot com scottsdaler.com
as well as i've dropped them in the room
two slack channel
as well if you want to grab the slides
now or
and i've also posted a link to the code
that i'll be using as well
so just to level set expectations really
quick
about some assumptions i had when i made
this talk
primarily i'm targeting.net core
developers as the title suggests
or people who are just familiar with
the.net core asp.net core ecosystem
and need to run a background task but
are maybe
unsure which options to choose from or
maybe you know all the different options
that are out there but
aren't quite sure when you should pick
one or the other
so those are all things we're going to
talk about today and get those questions
answered we're going to talk about what
are background tasks and jobs
like when do you use those exactly what
options are out there
why would i choose one over the other
and we'll do a deep dive into
each of these and understand really how
they work
and i'll do demos all throughout and
i'll also
pay attention to questions in the slack
channel as best
i can or at the very least i'll hit them
all at the end as well
so by the end of this hopefully you know
all your different options for running
background tasks
inside of net core as well as why you
would choose
one option over another
so quick who am i i'm a software
consultant
based in des moines iowa which is in the
center of the u.s
and currently my wife is corralling my
three and five-year-old daughters
upstairs so we'll see how well she does
but if you hear any laughing crying
screaming that may be what that is but
hopefully my mic doesn't pick all that
up
i am also the a co-organizer of the
iowa.net user group
i'm a friend of redgate and i blog as
well as i mentioned earlier
so before we talk about what options
there are for running background tasks
let's just first level set real quick on
why
what problems do background tasks solve
and what would you use them for
so the prototypical example is some sort
of cron
job some sort of uh job that kicks off
on some sort of timer
so you may pop messages off from a queue
every five minutes
or clean up your database or file system
every so often
or maybe every minute you want to check
should i send a payment reminder email
or sms
to my customers or maybe you want to
refresh
some distributed cash every so often and
we'll actually look at an example
of using these different background task
runners to refresh
a redis cache or maybe you want to check
for updates to a database every so often
and push those updates out through
signalr
whatever it is there's a million
different scenarios for cron jobs
that you could be doing out there and
i'm sure many of you have similar
operations such as these you may also
just want to perform some cpu intensive
work that's
outside of the normal request response
pipeline
in asp.net core so for instance if you
need to generate a million pdfs
you probably don't want to generate
those right when somebody clicks
the button you probably want to just
send them back a message saying hey we
got your message and we'll notify you
when that work is done
and spin up real quickly run all that
work and then spin it right back down
another example of what background tasks
solve is let's say you're doing some
machine learning stuff
and you need to retrain your machine
learning models
you could also do that on a background
task as well
and if anybody else has any other
examples dropping them in the chat
either in webex or slack i'm sure
that could spark some ideas for other
people of things that they could be
using background tasks for that maybe
they're not today
so we're going to talk about the top
four options here we're going to talk
about i hosted services background
services worker services
and hang fire and go into real
go deep into all four of those i will
touch
on some of the various cloud options
that are out there but i'm not going
to go into in depth about those
because ultimately you may be running on
azure and another person may be running
on aws
or gcp so if i focus on one particular
cloud
offering that may not make sense and may
segment the market
and some of the audience members may
not have that be applicable to them so
i'm going to target those
top four that you see there because you
can take those to any sort of cloud
or run it on-prem if that's your
scenario
so before we dive into the four options
i just kind of want to get this mental
model brewing
in people's heads and in my opinion
these options are kind of like baking
cookies
on one end of the spectrum you have
making your own recipe where you just
have the raw ingredients thrown in front
of you
and it's up to you to decide how you
want to assemble them how you want to
cook them
and you just have full control over how
you want to bake cookies
you can decide to make individual
cookies if you want or you can decide to
just make one monster cookie cake
it's kind of up to you but ultimately
you have full control but that means
also
there's more burden on you as well on
the other end of the spectrum
you have going to the grocery store the
supermarket
and buying cookies directly right off
the shelf
obviously that's way more convenient but
you have a lot less control over how
those cookies are made how they're
packaged
all that kind of stuff but depending on
your requirements you may choose to
grab something right off the shelf or
you may choose to
assemble your own cookie recipe it's
kind of up to you
so that's the mental model i'm going to
present when i talk about these four
options so the first one we're going to
talk about
is i hosted service and in my opinion
i hosted service is kind of one of those
make your own recipe
uh examples where you're going to have
the raw ingredients thrown out in front
of you
but the cookie jar is included and what
i mean by that
is the cookie jar is like the container
for your cookies
or for your code and in this case the
cookie jar represents asp.net core
and there's a little bit of a nuance
there of technically you can host
i hosted services outside of asp.net
core but
we'll talk about that nuance a little
bit later
so what is an ihosted service exactly
well it lets you host a background job
inside of an asp.net core app
where again asp.net core the asp.net
core app is your cookie jar
as the name suggests it is simply just
an interface
and that interface exposes two methods
that you need to implement
start async and stop async and i bet you
can guess what those two do
the way to think about i hosted service
is it's just this raw
low-level fundamental building block
that
other options and other components of
asp.net core itself build upon
including kestrel and we'll talk about
that a little bit later
you can register i hosted services
through dependency injection
using services dot add hosted of t
where t is the class that implements the
i hosted service interface
we'll take a look at that here
right now so i'm going to do
a demo of i hosted service
but before i do that i'm just going to
talk about what this project
that i have here contains so if i zoom
in here a little bit
i have the shared project that is going
to be used by multiple
different multiple projects multiple
examples here
and there's not much code in here
there's just a few different
pieces that i want to call out
specifically
so there's this cache service and i'll
zoom in if that's not good enough please
let me know in the chat
and i've got this cache service and it's
pretty simple
all it does is it takes in some
dependencies the i distributed cache
interface which comes off of
microsoft.extensions.distributed
and that package and then i'm just
implementing also injecting in a logger
and i've got this method here called
refresh dashboard cache async
and the idea behind this method is it
will
just generate some random data here
simulating like i'm making a database
call
so i've got this dashboard result class
that i'm going to be sticking into cash
and all that has is your average sale
the last time this was updated
and the number of sales so if i look at
that
as pretty simple poco and then we've
also got the total sales which is just a
calculation of the number of sales
times the average sale so you can think
of this as like
simulating a very expensive database
operation
or maybe api calls where you're
aggregating data from a lot of different
sources
and you don't want to make this call
every time somebody visits your
dashboard page
you just want to make it once every time
your cache refreshes and then you just
stick it in cache
and then your api serves up that data
from that cache
and here i'm just serializing the
results
and then i'm clicking it in
sorry can you okay sorry i think my
headset just cut out there for a little
bit
uh so then in here we're just going to
set it to the cache
the local redis instance that i have
running locally
and then we're going to log out some
information saying that hey
i've refreshed the cache and
everything's good to go
and then i just have a method here
that's removing
that cache key and purging whatever's in
my redis cache
from redis itself
so that's pretty much all you need to
know from that oh sorry one other thing
we have this service collections
extension here where i'm just
registering
that cache service that i talked about
and then i'm setting up some logging
to format the logger to
echo out the timestamp in a specific way
so then we can read the logs and see how
often the cache is refreshing
and then i'm just hooking up my local
redis instance here that again i'm just
running locally inside of docker
and i'm connecting it that way so then i
can reference this add demo services
method
in all of my projects
all right so if i go to my hosted
service example
let's just go ahead and start looking at
the startup first
so you don't really have to worry about
this configure method we're not really
doing anything crazy with
the asp.net core middleware pipeline
itself
all we're doing is registered risk
registering a
hosted service here using a services.ad
hosted service
and then giving it the implementation of
my i hosted service
and if we actually dive into what this
ad hosted service is doing
it's basically just doing a try ad
singleton
where triad singleton will guarantee
that you only register one instance
of that singleton so if you accidentally
call
this ad hosted service method multiple
times for the same hosted service
then you will actually only register one
single instance and not multiple
so that's all it's doing under the hood
it's just a convenience method
for try at singleton we're adding our
controllers
not too much crazy there if you've been
familiar with aspi core
and then we're registering the demo
services that i mentioned earlier
so let's go ahead and look at the hosted
service itself
you can see i'm just implementing the i
hosted service interface with this long
name
of dashboard cache refresher hosted
service
i bet you can't guess what my background
service is called
the exact same thing minus background
service and we'll get to that here in a
little bit
but you can see here i'm just injecting
in some resources here the logger and
that cache
service we looked at and then i've got
the start async method that's just
logging saying hey
i've started the app and then i'm
calling this refresh cache async method
which we'll look at here in a second but
the
other method i need to implement being
in i hosted service is stop async where
i'm just logging saying hey
i'm stopping this job and then i'm
performing
performing some cleanup where i'm just
clearing the cache in this case but you
can imagine
plugging in whatever cleanup that you
need to do here in stop async
inside of refresh cache async not too
much code here either
it's just saying hey while my
application is running so while
the application is not notified that i
am stopping
go ahead and try to refresh the cache
otherwise log out an
error and then wait five seconds and do
it all over again
for eternity until the application
notifies that
i am stopping so
that's a lot of talking let's go ahead
and just run the app
and see what it's doing under the hood
and i want you to note one thing
i am not awaiting this here and we'll
talk about why i'm not doing that here
in a second
so the application is booting
and let's just zoom in here on
the logs oh sorry one other thing i
forgot to mention
i do have a controller here it's pretty
simple controller
all i'm doing is grabbing the values
from the cache
and then returning them out so nothing
too crazy going on there at all
but if we go back to the logs from when
my application booted
you can see here that it's saying start
starting
this hosted service and you can see here
i'm saying starting this hosted service
and then you'll notice you'll notice
that says dashboard cache was refreshed
which is coming from this log statement
here so
my redis cache has been populated and
then you'll notice
a little bit later that now i'm
listening for requests and we'll talk
about
why this happens after the hosted
service has been registered
or after the hosted service has started
and then you'll notice every five
seconds it's simply refreshing the cache
here
so if i pull up my dashboard endpoint
you'll notice i've got this piece of
data here my refresh my random data will
then change
i refresh again notice it's the same for
about five seconds
and then the data updates so you can see
there
it just changed so this is an example of
how
you may use background services to
refresh some distributed cache
or maybe just an in-memory cache if
you've only got a single instance of
your application running
and this is also showing how you would
use hosted services that are kind of
like a raw fundamental
building block for the rest of this
all right
so how does ada how does ihosted service
work under the hood
well again you just register it with uh
dependency injection
using the services.add hosted service
there is a bit of a gacha with stop
async
so stop async's cancellation token by
default
gives you five seconds to shut down
gracefully
now this is assuming that there is a
great graceful shutdown initiated
so something like the app pools
recycling or something like that
however you shouldn't rely on stop async
to get called
because uh
rohan is asking to annotate i'm going to
say no
sorry sorry rohan um not really sure if
that would show up for everybody or how
that would work
but so stop async might not get called
if the app shuts
down in some unexpected way so you
should not be building your
hosted services assuming that star stop
async always gets called because
again there's no guarantee that it
actually gets called
so how does i and i hosted service work
then exactly
well you can see here kind of in the
center when aspiring core boots up
it's going to boot up all of your i
hosted services one after another and it
will actually do that
in the order that you register them in
your di container
but one thing that you'll note is at the
very end
after all the start async is complete
that's when kestrel actually boots and
starts listening for requests
so what this means is start async can
actually block
the rest of your app from starting so
in general you probably want to push
your blocking long-running work
outside of start async and this goes for
background service which we'll talk
about
a little bit later as well so in general
you probably want to do what you see on
the left which is you're not
awaiting your long running thing async
and
on the right you're waiting for that
long running async to finish
and the rest of your application will
not serve any requests if you're
co-locating your i-hosted service with
an api for instance your api or your
razer pages app or whatever
what whatever it is that your asp.net
core app does will not be able to serve
that traffic
until all of your i hosted services
complete start async
now maybe this is actually what you want
it to do so
an example of this would be maybe you
want to run your database migrations
inside of an i hosted service and so you
want your database migrations to apply
before your
application actually finishes booting
because maybe you don't want
those two to be out of sync although you
could argue
you should probably be making your
application
be able be fault tolerant to like your
database version -1
but we won't get into any of that but
like an example in my case maybe
i don't want the rest of my application
to boot unless that redis cache has been
populated so i could do something like
that
but with my current implementation if i
go back to this code
and say hey i actually want to await
this guy
and i'll make that async get rid of this
and
i'll rerun the application what will
happen here
is i'm going to wait for this to finish
but
it will actually never finish because my
while loop is saying
only finish when the application is
starting to shut down
so what will actually happen here is i'm
starting my hosted service oops let me
zoom in on that a little bit
i'm starting my hosted service but my
application never actually starts
listening for requests to comment or
starts listing for requests because
kestrel's not booting because i've never
finished
uh the work for my i hosted service so
if i try and make this api call again
i'm gonna get a timeout because again my
hosted service has not finished
so this is something that that i see
a lot and my headset kind of went out
again for a second there
this is something i see people get
tripped up on a lot where they think
that
they can just await or wait something
long running inside of start async but
that is actually not the case
and then they wonder why the rest of
their application is not booting
so that is a gotcha to look out for
so when do i use i hosted service well
you will use it implicitly with
background services and worker services
and actually hang fire as well
and you're actually using it implicitly
if you're
using kestrel inside of asp.net core
which i'm assuming all of you are and
but i don't think you should really use
it directly
unless you need full control over
starting and stopping
of your background job and you don't
want to use the base background service
implementation which we'll talk about
a little bit a little bit later
so when do i not use this in my opinion
you should be using something else such
as background services or worker
services
95 plus percent of the time other
reasons not to use it would be
the same as background service which
we'll talk about a little bit
er actually right now
so background services
background services if we go back to the
cookie analogy
are kind of like a follow the recipe
example
where you don't have the raw ingredients
laid out from in front of you
and you have to decide what recipe
you're going to follow and you're just
going to make one up on the fly
background service gives you a recipe to
follow
and the cookie jar is included where
again the cookie jar
is your asp.net core app so again
background services just lets you host
a background task runner inside of an
asp.net core app
and all a background service is is an
abstract class that implements the i
hosted service interface
and it exposes an execute async abstract
method
to you to put your custom code in
and background service handles some of
the starting and stopping logic with
cancellation tokens which we'll look at
here in a second
so you don't have to worry about dealing
with cancellation tokens if you're
unfamiliar with how
all those cancellation tokens and
everything work
so let's do a demo of background service
here
i'm just going to go ahead and close
that and open up the background service
again i'll start with the startup method
which looks
almost identical except the only change
is
instead of the dashboard cache refresher
hosted service i'm i'm registering the
dashboard cache refresher background
service
so there's no add background service
method i've seen people
wonder about that as well but
technically a background service
is a hosted service because it
implements that interface
so let's go ahead and look at this code
here
so you can see a big difference is i'm
inheriting from the background service
abstract class
i'm still injecting in the exact same
dependencies as before
but now i've got this start or this
execute async method
where when the job's starting i'm saying
hey
i'm going to log out i'm starting the
job and then i'll continue to do some
work
until the application shuts down the
exact same work i was doing earlier
where i was trying to refresh the cache
and then wait another five seconds and
then when the job ends
i stop i log out that i'm stopping and
then i remove
the or i purge the cache
so if i pull up the old code
and kind of look at these side by side
you can see the code is pretty similar
there's just
a little bit less code so we have 46
lines here on the left and 57 on the
right
so there's a little bit less code
because there's a little less spoiler
plate
that background service is actually
handling for us but
you can see here the start async method
this is identical to this
and then this code is all identical to
this
and this code right here and stop async
is identical to this
so if i go ahead and stop the old hosted
service
and launch my background service we will
see the exact same behavior
as the hosted service where it will just
refresh the cache
on a five second interval
and see here it says it says starting up
uh it's starting up and then it's
refreshed the cache now i'm
listening for castrol's booted up for me
and now i'm just refreshing that cache
every five seconds so again it's the
exact same behavior that we saw before
where my cache stays up-to-date for five
seconds
so exact same code just implemented in a
slightly different way using background
services
so how does a background service work
exactly
so background service works uh largely
the same way
you register it with the add hosted
service
just like you do with the hosted service
but then it exposes that execute async
abstract method that we just looked at
but you can still override start async
and stop async
if you need to do something super custom
so if i come back over here
i can still say hey override
and i'll get the options for start async
and stop async so
if you don't like the implementation of
what background service is doing
or you just need to hook into it in some
way you can still override that if you
want
so just to break down this code here
real quick because there's actually not
much code here that background service
is doing it's just kind of a convenience
class for you
so as you can see here there's not too
much code but let's go ahead and zoom in
on that real quick
so it's got the it's creating a
cancellation token source
and then it's also giving you that
abstract execute async method that you
need to
implement and then inside of start async
it's saying hey
i'm going to store off the task that you
have created here with execute async
and i'm going to pass the cancellation
token from this cancellation token
source and we'll
we'll take a look at how that all works
together here in a second
if the task is already completed go
ahead and bubble that up
otherwise it's starting to run so just
return a completed task
inside of stop async if the task has
not actually been called so if this line
here didn't actually
execute because it called stop before it
even called start
then go ahead and return out otherwise
tell that
cancellation token source to cancel
and you can see here that's the same
that stopping cts
field is the exact same field in both
spots so this is what's notifying your
execute async method that hey
the application is starting to stop and
then
down here we essentially have a race
where it's saying hey when
any of these tasks complete go ahead and
finish stopping so
either the executing task or the
cancellation token itself
that'll give you about five seconds to
stop if either of those complete
then go ahead and finish the method and
continue bubbling up
and move on to the next hosted service
that then has to stop
and on and on and on and then finally
just some cleanup in the dispose method
here
so not too much going on in the
background service and it actually takes
away some of the boilerplate so you
don't have to worry about it
so when do you use background service if
you need
a very simple background task runner
either as part of your asp.net core
application
like some existing api that you have or
if you want to run it by itself you
absolutely can
it's got a few less foot guns than i
hosted service does
so you can't accidentally prevent the
rest of your app from from booting
unless you override start async and
it handles the cancellation tokens for
you because a lot of times
we as developers may not do too much
with cancellation tokens so that may be
an unfamiliar concept to some people
so it kind of handles some of that
orchestration for you
another reason to use a background
service is if you want some sort of
asp.net core health check endpoint to
check how your background task is doing
this would be a benefit of background
services
over worker services which we'll talk
about here in a little bit
when do i not use background services
well
if you want to co-locate a background
service with an existing app or an api
if you register too many background
services that can get a little
unruly at times and can outweigh the
convenience of co-locating
because if you co-locate it with an
existing app
or like web app like a razer pages app
or an api
then you're going to be sharing the same
process you're going to be sharing the
same cpu memory network
all that kind of stuff so you could end
up in a noisy neighbor situation
where your background service is going a
little haywire which impact negatively
impacts the performance of your api
or vice versa if your api is getting
slammed it could negatively impact the
resources of the background service now
i'm not necessarily advocating for
putting background services in their own
process
just it's an it depends scenario of
which hurts less
putting them together and having one
deployable
or separating them and having two
different deployables that maybe
you need to maintain together
or deploy together or something like
that
another another thing
just went out again sorry my headset
went out on my side i'm not sure if
that's happening to you guys or not
but um anyway continuing on
my another thing that i've seen people
struggle with
is when they scale out it can be a
problem if your code isn't item potent
because say you scale out you have
multiple instances of the same
application running
you're now multiple instances of the
same background service running
so if your code is an item potent or
it's got some sort of locking mechanism
to ensure that only one is running out
of time or
you're popping messages off of a queue
that
that if you had a some sort of message
queue that
guaranteed only once delivery you could
avoid this as well
or you could just make your application
not allow scale out
um another situation where you can make
your code item potent is you could check
to see if the message has already been
processed
before you actually do the work that way
if you're like firing off emails from
your background service
uh if you fire off emails from your
background services you're not emailing
multiple times
i've seen people get tripped up on that
before with background services so just
a word of caution thinking about think
about scale out when you're creating
these things
so the next one we're going to talk
about is
worker services so what is a worker
service
a worker service essentially all it is
is an
enhanced net core console app template
that gives you a few more nice things
out of the box
so you can just go to the command line
and say dot net new worker
dash o and give it the folder name you
want it to spit
that code out to and it'll wire up a few
different things for you
when you do that it allows you to have
an eye host
so the same host that's used inside of
asp.net core
so things like configuration dependency
injection
logging all that good stuff that you
know with asp.net core
the worker service already has
pre-hooked up for you
on top of that it also creates a
registers a worker class
as a hosted service so it hooks it up to
di
as i mentioned earlier so all you have
to do from this point is just plug in
your custom code
and you're good to go now
what's different about a worker service
than some of these other things
is it does not take an opinion on how to
host a console app
so a worker service is kind of like a
follow the recipe
scenario but it's got no cookie jar it
has no
opinion on how you want to run your
worker service your console app
you could either call the console app
from a scheduler
like a window scheduled task or
kubernetes cron job or something like
that
or you could hook it up as a windows
service if you're on windows
or system d if you're on linux it's kind
of up to you
so let's do a demo of worker services
real quick i'm just going to declare
bankruptcy on my tabs here
and go into the worker service
so the first thing i'm going to look at
is the program
and as i as you might expect with the
console app you just have a
static void main oops static void main
that's creating your app
and then running it and you'll notice
this probably looks very familiar if
you've done asp.net core stuff
you're creating a host and let's just
ignore these two lines here for a second
but you're also configuring services and
i'm registering my demo services
and then i'm saying hey add me a hosted
service of
this worker class which is all
pre-configured for you
now these two lines here you can say
that
you want to host this inside of a
windows service
or inside of systemd and i've laid out
these package names here
with
microsoft.extensions.hosting.windowsservice.systemd
you can leave both of these here if
you're on linux this one will no op and
if you're on windows this one will no op
so if you're hosting it in this sort of
way
if you have developers on multiple os's
you can leave both of these here and
it'll work
when any developer pulls down the code
whether they're running on windows
or linux
so if i go in here and look at this
background server or this worker
class i you'll notice that this is
the exact same code as i had in my other
background service
and just to prove it to you i look up
the background service
and go ahead and push that off to the
side this code minus i was overriding
the start async
is 100 identical
so this is what i was mentioning earlier
when i said
background services and i hosted
services can technically run outside of
asp.net core
they can definitely run inside of things
like a worker service
but in general if you hear somebody say
hey i'm running a worker service
they probably mean inside of a console
app and if they say
i'm running a background service or an
i-hosted service
they probably mean asp.net core although
that one's a little bit
fuzzier but the cool thing is you could
plug in
this background service into an asp.i
core app and then decide later actually
you know what i need to bring that out
to its own process
because maybe it's causing some noisy
neighbor situations
and literally you don't really have to
change any code you can just take this
code and drop it into this worker
template
and everything else is kind of hooked up
for you you just need to decide
where am i going to host this how am i
going to kick this off how am i going to
install that
all that kind of stuff so that
abstraction
is pretty powerful
so how does a worker service work
exactly
well in your cs proj the
sdk type is of type worker instead of
web
and the other thing to note is it
automatically adds
a package reference to
microsoft.extensions.hosting
so that you get the whole i host create
default builder stuff
for you out of the box there's not too
much magic going on there behind the
scenes
so how do i host worker services then if
it's not an asp.net core app
well you could do something like a
scheduler calls your exe directly
so using something like windows schedule
tasks
azure logic apps kubernetes cron jobs
aws scheduled tasks
or gcp cloud scheduler or as i mentioned
earlier
you could run it as a windows service if
you're on windows or systemd
if you're on linux it's kind of up to
you on how you want to host your worker
services
when should i use worker services if you
want some sort of out-of-proc
way of running a background task so if
you don't want to co-locate it with your
existing asp.net core app
a worker service is a great option
as well as if you just prefer hosting
background services outside of the whole
web app life cycle because you can get
into some weird scenarios
where you know maybe an app pool
recycles
in the middle of your background task
running
and just making sure that your code can
handle that scenario
you can just get into some weird
scenarios with
kind of sticking a background task
runner inside of
a web app which is more about like
returning
responses from a request
i also think worker services are a
natural migration
for anybody who's got an existing
like.net 45 full framework windows
service
you can obviously like if you're happy
with that hosting model you can
obviously just port the code over to a
worker service
and hook it up to a windows service and
using a worker service and you'll be
good to go
when do i not use worker services well
if your team in general is more
comfortable deploying and maintaining
web apps
and you're not really too keen on having
like windows services or system d
or something like that maybe then you
would lean towards more something like a
background service
or hang fire which we'll talk about here
in a little bit
another reason not to use it would be is
if you wanted to co-locate
your worker service or your background
service with an existing
web app or api so maybe you don't want
to have multiple deployables
you just want like have something really
simple and you just want to host it with
your existing app
you can totally do that with a
background service not so much with a
worker service
another thing as if you want some sort
of health check endpoint
so obviously with an api you could add a
health check endpoint
saying hey is my worker is my background
service healthy is it processing
messages
all that kind of stuff with a worker
service you really can't do that because
it's just a console app
so for that you would have to do
something like monitoring the behavior
of the application
so if you're popping messages off of a
queue for instance
you would have to monitor how many
message messages are piling up on the
queue
and do some sort of alerting or whatever
you want to do on the health check
based off of that
so this next one we're going to talk
about is hang fire which i equate this
to buying pre-packaged cookies
and where they kind of made the decision
of how the cookies are assembled how
they're packaged and all that kind of
stuff
you just have to decide how are you
going to eat the cookies are you going
to use milk or however
you're going to eat the cookies that you
buy off the shelf
so hang fire's a open source library and
for running jobs in asp.net core
it is free for commute commercial use
but if you want support
or some extra features you'll have to
pay rent ranging from
oh i think i'd drop there again sorry
about that
uh as i mentioned it's free for
commercial use but paid if you want some
sort of support
such as 500 uh you'll have to pay
ranging from 500
a year to 4 500 a year
it comes with a ui for monitoring and
history so you can see how your jobs are
doing as well as how they've
well they've done in the past take a
look at that here in a second
it supports cron jobs so running things
on a timer or
just ad hoc running of jobs and we'll
take a look at that here in a second
if you just want to do a one-off job and
chuck some custom code into a job and
hang fire
it also allows for things called
continuations
where let's say you have step one step
two and step three and you need to
coordinate those steps and have that
happen in a particular order
it will allow you to set up these
continuations where it'll guarantee step
one
runs before step two and step two runs
before step three
it also supports automatic retries so
you can
it'll retry ten times by default but you
can also configure that how you like
and it supports concurrency limiting so
you can guarantee that a job
only runs one one instance of the job is
running instead of multiple instances
and it also persists the job state to a
database
and so you can we'll talk a little bit
later about how all that works
let's do a quick demo with hang fire
and i'm just going to declare bankruptcy
on my tabs again
and let's actually let's first open the
cs proj
and so you can see see how
what packages i brought in
so these are the three packages uh i
brought in
for hang fire so there's
hangfire.asp.net core
and this hooks hang fire up to the rest
of the asp.net core pipeline
and hang fire itself is actually
implemented as a i hosted service
so again yet another thing that builds
on top of i-hosted service
and then this is like the shared library
with all the common interfaces that hang
fire has
because you can actually run hang fire
on top of a full framework asp.net
like we were talking about before the
talks started
and then this is my persistence uh
package where i'm
saying i want to persist it to sql
server i could also persist it to redis
or msmq or i believe are the other two
options
so let's go ahead and look at my startup
for this
um i'm just registering some services
with hang fire
thing to note here's i'm saying i want
to use sql server and again i'm just
running sql server locally inside of
docker
so i'm saying hey this is my connection
string and then there's a bunch of
things that you can configure
uh if you want with hang fire
i'm registering the hang fire server to
do all the job processing
and then down here i'm hooking up some
of the middleware so i'm saying hey i
want to use the hang fire dashboard and
let's go ahead and map the hang fire
dashboard as well
and so if you want to kick off a or set
up
some sort of cron job you can do that a
few different ways but here's one of the
ways
so you can say recurring job dot add or
update and just give it an inline method
saying hey
i'm just going to call console.writeline
and i'm going to run that
every single minute or you can and so
when this persists to hang fire and
shows you in the ui
it doesn't really know anything about
this method so all it's going to tell
you is hey you ran a console.writeline
method so it just takes the method name
as the job name alternatively you can
give it
a specific job name so you just do that
with an attribute saying hey here's the
job i want to
display inside of hang fire let's go
ahead
and launch hang fire here
and so while that's coming up what this
will do
is it will launch the hang fire
dashboard so you can see
uh what's going on with all of your
different crown jobs
and monitor them so you can see like the
his
history graph of how many times these
jobs have run
and whether they've succeeded or failed
you get a real-time graph
showing you how much or how many times
they've succeeded or failed
you can see what recurring jobs you set
up so you can see i've got this one
that's console right line
which was that inline one that i showed
a bit ago and then i've got
this one here as well and you can see
it's got the custom name
of custom job name so i can actually go
ahead and trigger these
ad hoc if i want and
the console rightline one finished
immediately but you can see this one
took at least five seconds because i had
a five second delay here and then we can
go look at the history and see
okay this custom job name took 5.2
seconds
approximately to run and this console
write line one took
about 200 milliseconds i can dive into
the details
they're kind of telling me hey here's
what triggered it
here the different parameters how long
it took
what server it ran on all that kind of
stuff
another piece of code i have in here is
in the hang
this hang fire controller i've got a way
to kick off
a background job just kind of ad hoc so
if you have something like hey i want to
fire off an email
you can use this in queue method say
i want you to create a job and in this
case i'm saying hey
this is uh i'm passing the parameters of
hello from controller
and i'm actually using that inside of
the job name so this curly brace 0
is kind of like a string.format where
it's going to place in
the parameters that i passed to this
method so you'll see it'll say hello
from controller with
dash hello trigger from controller with
hello from the controller so if i come
over here
and make this api call to hang fire
simulate that api call you can see now
it's processing it's saying hey
triggered from controller hello from the
controller and go look at
how i performed and see what the
parameters were
and then how long it took and all that
same good stuff
you can also do things like deleting
jobs not sure why you would set up a job
just to delete it from a recurring
perspective but you totally can
if you wanted to like stop a job in the
middle technically when it's processing
you could also
check the box and say delete job as well
but let's say i throw an exception here
and just say oops something happened
right
i'm just going to rerun the app and i'll
show you kind of how the retries work
within hang fire
and writer's yelling at me saying i've
got some unreachable code which is fine
because i want that to happen
so my app speeded up if i refresh this
you can see immediately it chucked it
into this retry
queue and so it'll actually do an
exponential back off but i'll just keep
enqueuing it
and then it'll keep failing and you'll
see the back off will continue
increasing so now it's retrying in a
minute
instead of a second i enqueue it again
it'll enqueue uh in three minutes and
it'll just keep going on and on and on
eventually if these all fail it'll end
up into this failed
like dead letter queue essentially
saying hey this job failed and it never
succeeded
so that is a quick overview of hang fire
you could probably do a whole
hour-long talk on a hang fire if you
wanted but that's a quick overview of
some of the features
so how does it work as we were kind of
talking about earlier before this talk
started
uh it's saying fire serializes the
method call and all of its arguments
so it'll take those and it'll create a
background job based on that info
and then save that job to its persistent
storage so in my case that was sql
server
so the arguments to that and queue
method will actually go
into the database so in general you
don't want to put a lot of data in there
because that will end up in the database
you might want to just put like an id or
something like that
into your argument and then it'll start
the background job immediately
if it's like an enqueue situation where
you want to
start the background job immediately and
not delay it or be on some sort of crown
job
so when should you use hang fire if you
want to host jobs inside of asp.net core
and you need some of the features that
hang fire offers and you don't want to
write that plumbing code
yourself as well as if you're okay
relying
on a third-party open source library
whereas the other three options
that we talked about were kind of baked
into the dot-net core
framework itself when should you not use
hang fire
if you do not want to host your jobs in
asp.net core and you want to use
something like a worker service
because you want to avoid the uh likes
web server lifecycle then you would use
something like worker services over
hang fire and asp.net core
if you just have really basic needs and
you don't need hang fire's features
that would be another reason not to use
hang fire as well as if you don't want
to rely
on a third library and you want to
just use something more built into the
box like
background service
so
sorry sorry i think i'm back now i'm not
sure why my headset keeps doing that
but um another some other options that
you have
that i didn't really want to cover are
some of your cloud options so
i didn't want to cover these again
because in case you're on aws
if i cover azure functions that might
not apply to you
as well as there's a lot of talks here
at ndc sydney
on serverless options so but some of
these options
if they apply to you would be something
like azure functions
triggering off of a timer or an event
or azure web jobs same with
aws lambdas you can trigger those off of
some sort of cron schedule
or off of an event happening
a gcp cloud scheduler combined with
cloud functions could also
do similar things to what i've shown
here with
hosted services background services
worker services and hang fire but again
i didn't want to cover these to get very
cloud specific
so some takeaways hopefully i've brought
some awareness to
the options that are available to you
and maybe one of those resonated more
with you
so you can make the best decision for
you and your company or your client
and choose the best option that makes
sense for your scenarios
we've got some resources here so the
official microsoft documentation has a
bunch
of examples using background services
and hosted services
and worker services the official hang
fire docs
are at hangfire.io and then
steve gordon who's a prolific.net
blogger
he has a plural site on worker services
and hosted services
which by the way that pluralsight is
free this week
so you can go ahead and check that out
it's about a two hour long
course where he kind of dives into how
all this works under the hood
so with that i'll take any questions
people may have we've got about eight
minutes left if you want to drop them
into
slack or it looks like we've got a few
in the chat
here on webex
uh
looks like okay when your headset drops
out the audio stops for a second for the
audience but every time it start started
against all good
okay cool out of both the
implementations which one is good for
executing poly retries
so um it kind of depends on how you're
using
poly like i've used poly for use for
retrying like api calls and stuff like
that so to me that's kind of
irrelevant to running background tasks
themselves
it would just poly would be kind of
implemented inside of
my code and then i would still have like
a while loop
uh running on a timer or something like
that inside of a background service
where i just uh you know can try
catch i guess you could wrap the whole
thing inside of a poly policy
but um you just want to make sure that
your policy is obviously set up
correctly so then you can retry
appropriately
or kind of do what i did and just have a
try catch and just retry on some sort of
interval
when to go hang fire over web job
i'm guessing you're talking about azure
web jobs um
so a reason to use hang fire over azure
web jobs
obviously if you're on prem you would
probably choose hang fire since you
can't go to azure
um to be honest i haven't really used
azure web jobs in a while
so i'm not really sure why i would
choose web jobs over hang fire i'm
trying to think of a reason
but in general i would probably lean
towards using hang fire over web jobs
or lean towards like having an azure
function
trigger on some event like uh
some blob storage uh item getting added
or on some sort of schedule or
um something getting dropped into a
queue something like that so i'd
probably lean that
over web jobs in general if you want to
host something on azure and you don't
really want to go
all in on hang fire
if we are interested in doing something
for failed background tasks
could we hang handle those exceptions in
hang fire
uh yes so by default
if it throws an exception it will retry
those 10 times
but i've also written code before where
hey if it's some sort of transient
failure like the database is down or the
api is down
uh i'll just go ahead and keep retrying
but otherwise if it's some unexpected
error
like i've just got a bug in my code you
don't really want to retry that
10 times because it's just going to fail
10 times in a row and
if you have notifications hooked up to
your jobs failing
you're not going to find out for four or
five hours when that exponential back
off happens
so there's i can't remember the name of
it now there's a filter
that you can implement in hang fire to
say hey
um just bypass the failed state
or just immediately go to the failed
state and bypass the retry policy
so if you want to handle those certain
types of exceptions in a certain way
you can completely bypass the retry
policy and fail
fail hard and fail fast
and i'll try i'll i'll get the interface
for that and i'll post
an example in slack
which would be best for reading messages
from a queue and sending it to a stream
processor like kafka um
again it just kind of depends on whether
you want to host
inside of asp.net core if you want that
inside of a worker service it kind of
depends on
what your load constraints are if you
prefer having a health check endpoint
i don't know that there's really a best
one it's kind of
it depends on your various scenarios
sorry i know that answer isn't exactly
straightforward but it is
as always it depends in a microservice
architecture would you recommend hang
fire running on each microservice
would you have them share the same sql
database or
each microservice have their own hang
fire database
this is going to be another it depends
scenario um
basically it depends on hosting multiple
hang fire instances would you want them
to be unified under like a single
dashboard
or would you want them under multiple
dashboards
what's the load that you would have
those are the kind of questions that i
would ask of what kind of load would we
have maybe
if you have high load you would separate
those out into separate
hang fire instances but i'd definitely
run some sort of load tests to
understand what my constraints were
there
in general i lean towards making it easy
to operate so i would lean towards
unifying it under one dashboard you can
have multiple
servers and workers running on hang fire
so if you want need to distribute the
load you could add multiple servers
but then have them roll up under the
same dashboard
and they have documentation on how to do
all that
and if you have questions later you can
always reach out to me
through slack or hit me up on twitter or
you can go to my blog i've got a contact
page there too you can reach out to me
there as well